Hey! In this video, I'm gonna give you
young guys out there style tips to look
better. Now these are five style tips that
I wish I knew when I was younger, so
let's not waste any more time. Let's get
right into the video
Hey if you're new here to my channel, I'm Daniel and
welcome to DLM model lifestyle
subscribe and also click that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of the next videos. Now when I first
started my modeling career I always
wanted to look good, but my fashion
sense was zero. But over the years I
learned what really matters when it
comes to style and it's really good if
you can learn this at a young age and not
not struggle with it as I did over the
years and there was no one to really
help me with it. But as I said it's good for you to learn
this at a young age, because it's gonna
save you time, money and well let me just
start with the first step and you'll get
it:
You have to ignore fashion trends. Why?
Well here's the thing: Fashion trends
change too fast and you end up wasting
your money, rather invest in your future
and invest in quality clothing that will
never go out of style. Also whenever
there's a new fashion trend everybody
ends up looking the same. So you're not
really standing out at all. You know you
see what most models wear on the runway, but that doesn't mean we like it. I mean
there's some pretty weird stuff that we
will never wear, so the fashion industry
creates new clothes every now and then.
You fall for the media's advertising
tricks and you just spend your money and
before you know it there's new clothes
and there are new trends and you're out of
style. So this cycle just keeps on
repeating itself over and
again. So ignore more fashion trends
You gotta have self-confidence. Now you've probably heard this before on a lot of videos
But what does it mean when it
comes to style? Well it's not just about
what you wear, but it is about how you
wear it. Your clothes and your whole
image looks a lot better if you wear it
with a lot of self-confidence and it's
not about getting girls. It's about
what's deep in your soul, your driving
force. Knowing who you are and what you
stand for. Self-confidence is not "oh they
will like me". It's more like "I'll be fine
if they don't".
Take good care of your clothes
Yes, I know it's something
that your mom would say, right? But look
at me more like an older brother. Most
young guys don't have a lot of money to
spend on new clothes all the time. So when you buy something, take good care of it and
be proud of it and learn how to wash
your clothes the right way with the
right detergent and use a softener and
don't let it hang in the sun for hours
after you washed it and then also guys
learn how to iron your shirts properly
so that it doesn't leave any stains.
Buy quality clothing and not quantity.
Did you know that second to oil the clothing and textile industry is the largest
polluter in the world? 20% of global
wastewater is produced by the
fashion industry. People are just buying
and throwing away clothes like it's
nothing and they don't even realize that
they are destroying the earth. If you're not
part of the solution you're part of the
problem. In America alone 26 billion
pounds of textiles and clothes end up in
landfills but it doesn't have to!!
So focus on buying quality instead of
quantity. It will last you a lot longer,
you end up saving money and you look
better with quality clothes.
Wear clothes that fit your body.
Oversized baggy clothes never looks
good on anyone. I mean it's okay when you wear it at home when you want to relax
but when you go to events, wear clothing
that fits you well. When you look at
buying clothes the fit is very very
important so don't buy it if it doesn't
fit you. Now remember it's not about the
brand it's about style and style is
saying who you are without even speaking.
Now if you want to see some more style videos
check out one of these and if you
like this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe and we will talk soon
Cheers